bienvenue dans ce premier trois théories
de la saison 2 entre guillemets comme
certains savent déjà j'ai envie de faire
un peu de changements j'ai un peu envie
d'évoluer et donc j'aimerais tenter une
nouvelle chose donc n'hésitez pas à me
faire des retours sur le format bien il
est temps de se replonger dans du marvel
vous êtes beaucoup un rendement des et
franchement je suis content de reparler
et c'est l'occasion aujourd'hui avec le
sujet des nouveaux avengers mais avant
tout j'aimerais vous prévenir que cette
vidéo est sponsorisé par north vpn
un grand merci à eux effectivement
aujourd'hui je ne suis plus étudiant et
je dois vivre par mes propres moyens
je ne vous cache pas que cela va m'aider
a clairement m'investir encore plus dans
la chaîne et notamment des ménages et
yes alors neuf et pnc quoi premièrement
nantes vpn vous permet tout d'abord de
sécuriser vos informations en ligne et
chiffrer vos données afin de vous rendre
invulnérable sur internet
mais l'utilité principale d'un vpn et
notamment nord de vpn c'est de pouvoir
se situer dans n'importe quel pays tout
en restant chez vous nous pouvons
prendre l'exemple de disney + déjà
disponible aux us mais pas en france
avec north bay pnc donc possible
d'accéder à la plate forme tout en
restant chez vous au attendez j'ai une
meilleure et et admettons vous avez
envie de vous relater le premier trois
théories d'origine sur interstellar
bloqués dont plus de 239 pays
et bien pas de souci grâce à une lampe
vpn
il vous suffit de vous localiser au
canada aux états unis et vous pourrez
revoir la vidéo comme si de rien n'était
alors j interviens car j'ai omis de vous
partager certaines informations
effectivement dans bp n est extrêmement
simple d'utilisation et c'est un gros
point fort l'application est disponible
sur un maximum de 6 appareils connectés
au même moment et vous permet d'accéder
à plus de 5500 serveurs disponibles dans
plus de 60 pays
d'ailleurs le partage en peer to peer
est également autorisé et ce sans que
votre ip ne soit dévoilé donc aucun
risque de traçage
bref si vous êtes intéressés par notre
vpn un lien vous est disponible dans la
description vous permettant de vous
procurer un accès
ce lien est ce code promo argot rock
vous permettra de bénéficier d'une
réduction de 70% sur votre abonnement ce
qui vous reviendra à ne payer que 3
euros 17 par mois d'ailleurs sachez que
si vous prenez l'abonnement trois ans
vous aurez d'office quatre mois
gratuites offertes et l'application de
cryptage de fichiers nord glock
merci de m'avoir écouté bon allez
maintenant passons aux théories il ya
trop de choses à dire ça va être trop
dur d'être concile qui dit nouveau
avengers dit forcément nouvelle équipe
l'équipe d'origine et en plus ce
qu'elles étaient il est évident que de
nouveaux héros vont reprendre le
flambeau et continue et ce pour quoi les
six premiers avenger se battaient déjà
le terme d' avengers est donné à tous
héros combattant aux côtés de l'équipe
des avengers d'origine du mc hugh mais
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous parler d'une
nouvelle équipe qui pourrait vraiment
ressembler à l'ancienne donc
malheureusement pour moi les héros comme
les gardiens de la galaxie ou même
docteur strange reste des héros à part
des héros qui seront présents par
moments mais qui ont d'autres
préoccupations que de sauver la terre la
terre tient pour rester dans la
cohérence et afin d'éviter de perdre le
spectateur les avenger sont et seront
toujours principalement sur la terre
c'est un fait bien que marvel souhaitent
s'orienter vers une direction beaucoup
plus cosmique
la terre est et sera toujours centrale
prenons l'exemple d'une infiniti war ou
encore endgame l'intriguent des deux
films se joue principalement et se finit
toujours sur la terre que ce soit les
deux claquements de doigts ou même la
présence des pierres la majorité se
retrouve sur terre où sont réunies à cet
endroit
ce n'est pas un hasard c'est un
véritable choix pour justement mieux
appréhender la saga à ceux qui n'ont pas
lu les comics bref beaucoup de l'icc et
de spéculations sont apparus pour cette
nouvelle équipe mais rien de vraiment
officiel
alors j'aimerais vous proposer ma vision
subjective sur qui pourrait faire partie
d'une nouvelle véritable équipe
centré sur la terre et ses horizons déjà
spider man
comment ne pas parler de peter parker
l'avenger ce qui va nous montrer la plus
grande courbe d'évolution dans le futur
du mc et les phases à venir
ce dernier marche réellement dans les
pas de son mentor tony stark
la jeune araignée va devoir comme tony
gérer sa célébrité naissante
étant donné que malheureusement pour lui
son identité fut révélée par mystérieux
peter par le biais de son second film
far from omv a grandi
que ce soit psychologiquement ou en
maturité notamment à cause des
tromperies des trahisons et sa naïveté
due à sa jeunesse il est le symbole de
la nouveauté et de l'avenir
il n'y a aucun doute là dessus ensuite
il faut vraiment qu'on parle de blague
panthères je ne sais pas si on se rend
vraiment compte
mecha là et probablement l'avenger ce le
plus important pour le futur de marvel
il a tout d'abord énormément côtoyer les
premiers avenger ce malgré sa présence
récente dans le mc mais surtout xala et
le roi du wakanda il a la confiance de
son peuple et le profil d'un véritable
leader que ce soit sur l'aspect
stratégique au combat comme dans
infinity world games mais aussi sur
l'aspect politique
rappelez vous de l'histoire des accords
de soko vie la panthère a le pouvoir et
les moyens de se confronter aux plus
grands de la terre d'ailleurs le wakanda
lui permettra de fournir argent et
notamment une nouvelle base pour la
nouvelle équipe des avengers à l'avenir
son second film tout comme le troisième
opus de spider man se passeront lors de
la phase 5
je pense que ce n'est pas du tout un
hasard next top il est clair que son
histoire va prendre un tout autre
tournant dans l'avenir du mc entre quête
de sagesse et de pouvoir il est fort
probable que thor marche sur les traces
de son père odin pour accomplir son
destin
néanmoins vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
que thor love and thunder soit le
quatrième film de thor est prévue pour
la fin de la phase 4 et introduira le
personnage de mighty thor incarnée par
l'ex petite copine de thor dans ses
premiers films nous sommes clairement
face un passage de flambeau du rôle
entre l'ex roi d'asgard et la jeune
protagoniste étant d'ailleurs une
terrienne ses préoccupations seront
centrées sur cette planète ce qui
concorde avec l'idée d'une nouvelle
équipe et l'idée que thor peu avancé
pleinement dans l'univers pour accomplir
son destin ou ses quêtes
enfin faut qu'on est pour moi une
évidence pour cette nouvelle équipe des
avengers
le nouveau captain america du mc où il
aura un grand rôle à jouer accompagné de
son acolyte de toujours bus qui passent
néanmoins but qui restera toujours
secondaire
effectivement son passif trop sombre et
son vécu l'empêcheront de devenir un
nouvel avengers mais bucky comme war
machine ou encore hulk feront partie de
ces futurs héros plus secondaire mais
qui aideront les nouveaux avengers dans
leur quête
on parlait de hulk il est compliqué de
déterminer parmi les nouvelles têtes à
venir qui pourraient s'intégrer
pleinement
collectif mais je verrais bien she hulk
comme mighty thor ce serait un passage
de flambeau entre hulk et cette nouvelle
héroïne qui d'ailleurs est très présente
dans les nouveaux comics marvel pareil
pour shanxi
ce dernier n'ayant aucun super pouvoir
mais étant un expert des arts martiaux
nous aurions comme une sorte de black
widow ou deux hawkeye en améliorer l'
idée d'ailleurs pas mal aussi suspecté
mais je ne le connais pas encore assez
en tout cas si je n'ai pas mentionné un
héros précis c'est que pour moi il n'a
pas les toffes ou tout simplement il n'a
pas lé l'envi de faire partie pleinement
de cette nouvelle équipe des avengers
donc c'est une vision totalement
subjective comme vous vous en doutez a
vous de me dire votre propre avis dans
les commentaires
et qui pour vous ferez partie des
nouveaux avengers far from home nous
introduit quelque chose de complètement
fou
nick fiori et dans l'espace et talos a
pris sa place sur terre en attendant et
parmi les héros que je n'ai pas cités
auparavant
nous avons évidemment qu'un rôle denver
ce aka captain marvel et si je ne mets
pas mentionné ce n'est pas pour rien
tout d'abord un mystère se doit d'être
résolue on ne sait pas depuis combien de
temps talos a pris la place de nick fury
et c'est un fait
beaucoup pensent que cela d'attrait
depuis civil war ou mick jury s'était
fait passer pour mort où certains
pensent carrément que c'est une copie
depuis le tout premier ironman
bon vous allez droit de penser ça mais
vous allez me demander quel rapport avec
les nouveaux avengers
je vous explique déjà le film de captain
marvel s'est terminée sur la scène de
l'héroïne quittant la terre aux côtés de
talos et du peuple scroll et il faut
intégrer une chose si skrull il y a
captain marvel il sera qu'à ça beau
proverbe ça c'est très simple carroll a
fait de la quête des skrull qui sont en
guerre contre les cris sa principale
activité est à l'os lui doit beaucoup
lui et ses semblables ont une dette
infinie envers carole c'est pourquoi
toutes les actions de talos mené à
l'écran sont pour moi justifiée par un
ordre de carole fiori étant un
personnage très proche de l'héroïne je
parle de carole un pas de la drogue
talos est donc présent pour carole mais
aussi pour fiori du coup bref les amis
de mes amis sont mes amis
vous connaissez le dicton en fait pour
moi la scène post credit d'in fi nit
ivoire est très révélatrice est très
personnel voyant que l'univers s'écroule
et que son premier pilier tony stark ne
répond plus fiori appelle donc carole sa
sauveuse ultime d'allos lui l'heureux
déjà appelé bien avant je ne sais pas si
vous voyez ce que je veux dire vu qu'il
connaissait aucun autre héros quoi bref
tout ça pour vous dire que pour moi nick
fury dans l'espace aux côtés de carole
depuis sa réapparition
c'est à dire après avengers ngue s'il
est en compagnie des skrulls
et s'il est dans l'espace c'est
obligatoirement aux côtés de carole le
personnage ans qui fiori a le plus
confiance dans l'univers mais du coup
que fait fiori dans l'espace et pourquoi
on parle autant de lui alors que le
sujet ce sont les nouveaux avengers
fiori est à l'origine des avengers comme
vous le savez déjà et son personnage est
ultra important pour la réunification
des avengers la conception de l'équipe
ou encore tout le côté administratif en
quelque sorte la liaison avec les gens
haut placés quoi bref si fiori dans
l'espace ce n'est pas beau rien surtout
s'il est de mèche avec les skrulls
cela veut dire que fiori a déployé le
solde bref j'ai un mauvais axemble qui
comme son nom l'indiqué est une variante
du shield mais plutôt orientée dans la
taxe soit en gros le shield directement
dans l'espace ce qui souligne très
fortement que captain marvel a rejoint
les rangs définitivement le joueur
dirigée par nick fury composé de scroll
est accompagné de captain marvel
bref l'idée me plaît beaucoup
franchement on ne peut pas affirmer si
fiori est à la recherche de quelque
chose de précis dans l'espace mais cela
promet une nouvelle menace à venir dans
l'univers et ce qui m'intrigue beaucoup
c'est que samuel jackson l'acteur de
fiori avait toujours affirmé qu'il
aimerait que son personnage le jour où
il devra mourir s'éteindrait dans
l'espace et non sur terre la route
commence à ce tracé il est clair que
fiori n'est pas éternel et samuel
jackson a aujourd'hui soixante dix ans
sa présence dans l'espace et surtout
suite au prologue de la phase 3 de
marvel souligne forcément un lien avec
l'avenir cosmique des nouveaux avengers
sa mort pourrait être un symbole du
futur de marvel laissant la place à la
nouveauté
les nouveaux avengers et possiblement
une nouvelle figure charismatique
dirigeant le sword et le shield dans
tous les cas si fiori devait mourir cela
mettra une énorme claque à carole et
dieu sait qu'elle en a besoin
pour évoluer nous parlerons bientôt de
son cas dans une vidéo des digues
carroll a beau être la plus puissante
des avengers ce n'est pas une ts et il
faut qu'elle redescende dans son ego
c'est là le point culminant son
évolution dans le m c est ce qui fait
d'ailleurs aussi son chat
[Musique]
le 15 octobre 2019 une photo a été
publiée sur la toile
tweetez est directement par la personne
concernée c'est ryan reynolds dans les
studios de marvel ce dernier s'est
entretenu avec kevin fait guère et on
sait très bien de quoi ils ont parlé
il a tellement d'informations et de
spéculations qu'on pourra en faire une
vidéo dédiée mais essayons d'être concis
comme je lé toujours imaginé oui je l
avoue des poules serait le pont entre
les héros de la fox et l'univers du mc
effectivement nous sommes face à un
mutant hors du commun plutôt solitaire
et qui aujourd'hui s'amuse à voyager
dans le temps ce dernier le cap parfait
pour introduire les héros de la fox
comme une sorte de représentant
c'est un symbole de ce que nous savons
marvel a pour projet d'intégrer des
poules l'om s'est lui dit si la phase 5
est notamment avec son troisième film
dédié mais il se pourrait que ce dernier
s'y intègre bien avant d'après des
sources récentes il se pourrait que des
poules s'incruste par moments dans
certains films de la phase 4 comme une
sorte de cameo et cela veut tout dire
pour moi effectivement pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas compris la phase iv est
transitoire et sert d'introduction à la
suite du mc hugh notamment la phase 5
donc elles servent principalement à
présenter les nouveaux héros continuer
l'histoire des anciens et c est ici le
même procédé que pour le teasing de
thanos ou tout autre grand méchant
seraient utilisés je m'explique faire un
cours caméo dans plusieurs films permet
d'utiliser le personnage et nous faire
comprendre que quelque chose d'énorme va
arriver repensez à toute l'histoire du
mc eu avec les scène post générique aux
apparitions de thanos c'est exactement
la même chose pour en revenir au nouveau
avengers il faut pour moi un film pour
faire démarrer cette nouvelle équipe
comme à l'époque avec la venture un fou
nos premiers et rechercher la cohésion
d'équipé une entente
bref il se découvrait l'eau qui en tant
que méchant était parfait car ce n'était
pas un si gros méchant que ça
la preuve en est tout le monde aime
l'eau qui par la suite ici c'est
exactement pareil des poules pourrait
semer la discorde pour une séquelle
raison dans le monde du mc eu peut-être
dû à une folie naissante du à ses
nombreux voyages dans le temps ou
possiblement voyage entre les réalités
du coup petite parenthèse ailleurs on
sait pas du tout comment il va rejoindre
duhaime s'est vu ça c'est un mystère
bref les nouveaux héros pourrait alors
se battre contre des poules avant que ce
dernier ne rejoigne leur équipe par la
suite est ce que vous voyez l'idée si je
vous dis tout ça ce n'est pas pour rien
car marvel aurait peut-être un projet
pour un film se nommant deadpool contre
le mca et c'est là que la liaison avec
les nouveaux avengers doit se faire au
début de la phase 5
ce film symboliserait le tout premier
des nouveaux avengers mais également le
premier du mc eu avec un mutant x men
bref où x force si vous préférez hashtag
mdr lol le lancement véritable de cette
nouvelle phase qui s'annonce beaucoup
plus corsée et cosmique que tout ce que
nous avons connu pour le moment et bull
étant d'ailleurs un terrien cela me
conforte dans l'idée qu'il serait le
premier ennemi entre guillemets des
nouveaux avengers qui normalement
seraient eux aussi principalement sur
terre permettant ensuite à des pools
d'intégrer et faire connaître les x men
au monde du mc eu et bien plus encore
écoutez c'est la fin de cette vidéo
merci à tous d'avoir suivi et un très
grand merci à north bay pn de l'avoir
sponsorisés je suis très curieux d'avoir
vos avis sur ce nouveau format entre
guillemets et j'aimerais également vous
prévenir que je serai présent au
bordeaux geek festival avec aero
semestre thibault dennis ead layton pour
faire des dédicaces et des conférences
notamment sur l'univers de marvel
je voulais également vous spécifiez que
je suis très actif maintenant sur
instagram twitter et du coup je vous
encourage très fortement à me suivre sur
ces deux réseaux
et puis le côté n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à lâcher un petit pouce bleus on
se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos etc ou tester argot rock
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]